see the world through other people's
eyes now empathy is a quality of
character that can change the world my
name is Jang Shin I am the uh Deputy
principal of a high school in Beijing
called ping University High School uh
we're affiliated with the university
picking University I was born in China
um but I grew up in Toronto Canada and
from my undergraduate I was at Yo
college and after graduating in 1999
I've been working in China since then in
different capacities U first as a high
school teacher and then as a journalist
um a documentary filmmaker and now I for
the past four years I've been working in
study of broad education in China so I I
I just brought up your uh school here
the uh peing University High School
that's right I'm bringing up the U the
web page here and so what is this school
about right so um the high school itself
was founded in 1960 um as a lab school
for picking University um so a lot of
the uh professors got their training
here here in the high school and a lot
of the children of professors um sent
their CH sent their children here and so
since 1960 this has been a very much an
Innovative Progressive High School in in
China um so a lot of top scientists have
graduated from here a lot of top
thinkers one of China's most famous
entrepreneurs his name is uh Wong Yan um
and he is founder of a internet portal
called sin.com um they're very famous
for the for their Twitter site called sa
weor and he's a graduate of this um high
school so a lot of you know very famous
scientists very famous entrepreneurs
graduate from from this high school um
and what makes this High School very
interesting is the sort of community um
the sort of interactions between between
the teachers and the uh the students
it's a very much it's very much a very
nurturing and encouraging environment so
in 2010 we started a new uh Department
of this high school called the
international division since about 2005
2016 more and more Chinese students um
were applying to study in United States
um this has you know City abroad has
been in China since about the mid90s but
primarily these are students who didn't
do very well in the Chinese system and
so they opted to go to school in
Australia and Britain and Canada um
about 2005 2006 America relaxed its visa
restrictions against Chinese students
and what we what we started seeing then
were were a lot of top students um who
could have gone to Pik University and
chai University um choosing to go to
America instead and this trend has only
accelerated since then so today you have
about 160,000 Chinese students right now
studying on the American campus wow um
and and you have entire you have entire
classes opting out of the Chinese system
and choosing to go to America in instead
so this has become a um a huge Trend in
in China and so we started in
2010 um to meet student demand but more
as an experiment um more as a lab within
a lab school to see what what was
possible um in terms of Education reform
in China okay yes so if I could just
interrupt here is the way we connected
is that you've created a a proposal for
the competition the shoka competition
for activating empathy how to promote
empathy in the schools and uh you're
since you're a very Progressive school I
imagine that that's why uh you you know
that empathy tends to be part of
progressive schools and so can you tell
me about your proposal uh that you did
for the Ashoka
competition right empathy itself is not
a very well-known Concept in China in
fact there's actually no Chinese word
for empathy we've been trying for the
past two years trying to translate the
word it's very hard to translate I mean
there's a word for um sympathy which is
the same feeling empathy isn't really
the same thing and um so I mean for the
past few years there's this huge debate
right now in China there's a consensus
that the Chinese system doesn't work um
and so one question that they have
Chinese like to ask is why has CH China
not produce a Nobel price winner in The
Sciences why doesn't China produce
Innovative entrepreneurs like Steve Jobs
and Mark zuckman and Bill Gates and I
think that the key here and this is
something that's discuss in in China is
I think the key is empathy I think
creativity and empathy are directly
linked empathy leads to to creativity so
um so here we're trying to educate
China's next generation of creative
thinkers the um entrepreneurs the
writers the um scientists the Educators
that are going to lead China into the
21st century and for for us the
fundamental Essence has to be empathy
because empathy is basis for
collaboration of course um understanding
um group dynamic and understanding the
need to work with others but also
communication effective
communication requires understanding the
Viewpoint of the other person but also I
believe very strongly in creativity um
in understanding yourself and
understanding different people and it's
this constant negotiation with who you
are and with what the world demands that
would lead to new
ideas oh so so you're saying that in in
China the the country feels that it's
education system is not uh producing
maybe the top people or or the most
creative people and that and you're
really feeling that empathy is this
foundation for
creativity uh and maybe something that
uh China needs to implement uh
Countrywide yeah I mean I mean right now
in China there's a fundamental shift in
the society um you know for the past 20
30 years China was very much a
manufacturing based economy so I mean a
very blunt way of saying this is that
China was a sweatsh up to the world it
was manufacturing Goods uh in its Pro
River Delta Region and then exploring
them elsewhere so I mean all the
Innovation was happening elsewhere but
all the manufacturing sort of uh labor
intensive work was happening within
China um and so that that was fine for
you know 20 30 years because China was
an agricultural um society and to
transfer to an industrial society mean a
rap
um um increase in wealth and you're
talking about 8 to 10% GDP growth a year
and so you had um massive um wealth
generation because of the shift from an
from an agricultural based society to a
manufacturing based society um and if
you're manufacturing based society then
what you need are literate workers uh
who are able to execute simple tasks and
that's what the China system is very
good at doing it's very good at at
producing disciplined focused
individuals who can read and write right
and the way it does that is by using the
using standardized examinations um to
sort of filter out uh who succeeds and
and and who fails and this sort of
motivation system works fine but what
we're finding now is that as is that
China cannot shift from a manufacturing
based uh economy into a knowledge based
economy because of this education system
um students are not required to think
for themselves they have absolutely no
motivation to study outside this um this
this the school system so you know um
you know about 10 20 10 years ago
Richard Florida wrote this book called
The Rise of the creative class about
individuals who are constantly learning
who are constantly chall them
challenging themselves who who learn for
the sake of of learning um Daniel pink
wrote this book called Drive which talks
about motivation 3.0 which is um which
is the intrinsic Drive uh the um the
motivation from within to improve
yourself and that's very much what try
to right now and because because of that
China cannot progress as society and and
as economy and and so there's this
fundamental debate about how China can
best transition from a manufacturing
based um economy into a knowledge based
economy and our solution here is empathy
empathy has to be um the fundamental
essence of of China's um shift from um a
cized test um exam system into a more
Progressive um education system and for
for for the past two years we've been
really focusing on empathy um in our
system can I just add you are you
focusing specifically on the word
empathy I mean are you actually using it
among the uh the staff and the
professors and the and the and the
students are you saying hey we need to
do empathy we need to Foster empathy so
is it very conscious and explicit like
that um you know we use the word
explicitly um but you know for us it's
very hard to translate into Chinese and
so there there lacks a understanding of
a concept here and so we use different
ideas to express the same thing empathy
so we talk about collaboration we talk
about communication we talk about group
dynamic we talk about um we talk about
self-learning we talk about self-
understanding we talk about self-control
these are all fundamental concepts that
are related to empathy so we ourselves
don't actually use a term in um in our
communication to parents and to students
but it very much is is in the background
well what do you do then uh what I'm
really what I'm really looking at is uh
how do we build a culture of empathy so
it's like uh Asoka is focused on empathy
you know creating a culture of empathy
with schools I'm looking at how do we
build a culture of empathy within
schools within businesses within the
home and a whole societal wide cultural
shift so I'm really interested in in
kind of any insights you have you know
from your school like what are the
things you do to you know build that
culture yes um that's a great question
and you know my answer is that humans
through Evolution have been sort of
programmed designed um to be um to be
individuals with empathy a culture of
empathy is a natural state of we're
wired for empathy
basically EXC me we're wired for empathy
just through m and
biologically I mean I mean think about
this I mean like we have families right
we have we have friends we have
colleagues um in order to communicate
with them in order in order to do
effectiv with them we need empathy so
empathy is really fundamentally about
being a human being and so the question
is why is it in China um China is not
very much an a society based on empathy
um and why is it in America you know you
have these you have these um you know
Wall Street scandals uh and so what's
happening in this world that is reducing
the level of empathy um and I think a
lot of it is are um sort of increasing
focus on material um on on materialistic
ends money and tests and so you know it
where our school is a clear example of
this where where our students came in um
products of the Chinese system sem
examinations incentive based learning
and what we've done here is B basically
eliminated that culture and we said here
you've come in to learn at to be
individuals and to be thinkers um and we
don't want short-term goals learning is
a lifelong process this is a message
that we we communicate them all the time
you know they come in and they think oh
my my job is to do well on the SAT my
job is to do well on on the tofl and get
into a top American school and and so
what we say to them is if you come in
here with that sort of attitude it's the
same attitude as in a Chinese system
where you do well on examinations in
order to get into top Chinese um schools
and that's the reason why um a lot many
chines students lack empathy because um
you know and I mean the science isn't
very clear on this but um they've done
all lot experiments to show that people
have two two centers there's the
altruistic creative Center and there's
another utilitarian short-term Center so
another way another another way another
way of saying this is that you know
these two centers are mutually exclusive
you can choose to tell students okay
you're in school to be a better
individual or you can choose to tell the
student you're in school to do all
onized examination so you can get into a
top college you can choose one of the
other you cannot choose both um and what
happens often is that if you use the
same message um it's the short-term
utilitarian Center that over writes the
altruistic moral creative Center and
that's what we've discovered in uh in
our prog program where by by constantly
negating the util utilitarian Drive the
short-term thinking Drive students have
become more creative um more empathic
more moral individuals and that's
something that that we're extremely
proud of and we constantly reinforce
this through um you know the focus on
group dynamic in our classes um on
having the kids do group work and
telling the kids that um you know just
because you do well on test does not
mean that you're smart being smart means
the ability to work with different
people and to recognize the strengths of
other people and how to match your
strengths with the strengths of of other
people to to to produce something great
and and Lasting and creative that's what
we tell them um last month we sent our
our students to
Botswana um to do a service learning
there to work with AIDS orphans and to
um work with disable children and that
obviously was intellectually very
challenging and to like to shift from
one culture uh to another culture and to
uh adapt that requires empathy um that
and and so they were able to do that I
mean we sent two teachers to um
constantly work with them and help have
them process the The Experience so that
way is that way I mean one way of
developing empathy is just kind of meet
a lot of people and get a lot of
experience I I for example went
traveling around the world I was like 17
and graduated from high school here and
I traveled for 10 years around the world
and just started seeing that people were
just like me in the sense that we had
that common Humanity so you're saying
you're kind of taking the students and
getting them to get out into uh
different environments I mean about
swana Africa and probably pover
situations we s our students to batswana
and they came back to transform but I
think that that's 9% of it there there's
one 0 that's about 90% 90% but there's
also another very fun fundamental part
here which is why they go They're going
to meet new people and to expand
Horizons it I mean like it reframed it
as oh you're going to go because this
will look good on your college
application then you know they go in
with a different motivation and they
would not get as much of experience and
they would come back um you know not as
transformed as they could have been so
so again I think it's very fundamental
to tell our students and and you know to
sort of our society both in China and
America needs to move away from society
that seeks short-term materialistic
rewards and um and goals and towards a
more sort of um holistic thinking a more
um altruistic um Society based sort of
thinking you know I think America and
China right now are both too much
focused on the individual on on
short-term uh goals like you know test
scores and and money so it's the short
term just going for the immediate
gratification the immediate goals
instead of looking at the larger picture
perhaps and in fact I think in in terms
of empathy is that empathy seems to
takes a wide space awareness it's like
if you're like working on a short-term
goal takes a real focus in a closing of
awareness and empathy seems to take this
opening of of awareness to take in more
so if so I think kind of dynamically
biologically that that kind of overlaps
with with what you're talking about
that's right you know I think empathy is
related to a lot of things again I don't
know the neuros signs Behind these
things and you know no one has yet
figured it out but I think empathy
morality altruism creativity are all
linked together somehow um and I think
one one reinforces the the other well
here's the thing is is what is your
definition of empathy how are you
defining it um what's your kind of
operating
definition right I mean empathy I
considered you know I mean the technical
term is called theory of mind which
basically is the ability to perceive and
understand and accept the viewpoints of
others that are fundamentally different
from from yours you know it's very easy
for us to um know what we think and to
express what we think but the ability to
sort of sympathize or understand what
other people think and to articulate
their Viewpoint that's empathy and that
that intellectually is um you know just
just just from an intelligence
perspective the most intellectual thing
that a human being can can do the
ability to like articulate to so
basically read other read another
person's
mind um can I it share with you my uh
definition of empathy that I've kind of
I've looked at a lot of different uh
definitions of empathy and kind of been
putting them together and I've come up
with kind of like a four parts to
empathy and the first part I would call
Self empathy so that's like
self-awareness mindfulness uh sensory
awareness of of the feelings that are
within my body you know feeling feeling
my own pinching of myself and feeling
the sensation so it's like it's this
sensory awareness of what's going on in
me from a feeling sensation level then
there's the mirror neurons uh or what I
call mirrored empathy which is as you're
watching me and you're seeing these
hands kind of Ling around that your body
is
mirroring that those motions within you
and you can feel that to varying degrees
the more open you are and broader your
awareness is the more you can feel and
have that uh mirrored empathy through
the physical uh process of mirror
neurons then there's the uh theory of
mind more area which is uh what I call
imaginative empathy or sometime called
perspective take or cognitive empathy so
it's it's uh being able to take the the
position of someone else see the world
like what is it like from their position
kind of in
perspective and that has more of a
cognitive you know imaginative quality
to it and then the fourth part is what I
would call empathic action that as we as
we connect at these other levels and are
able to see each other and feel each
other other that we create action
together that is an empathic type of
action where there's no uh a barriers to
the action like you know when people are
mad at each other and they try to work
together I mean it's just like terrible
you know it just doesn't work but when
they you're really well connected with
someone then you have this empathic
smooth that's right action so that's
kind of the the the the working
definition that I use yeah I mean like
you know you're really talking about the
four stage of empathy right and and how
they build on each other the first stage
second stage the third stage the fourth
stage you know another um another
framework for understand this is is um
you know what Educators call the
individualization and the socialization
process where you first have to become
an individual before you can U properly
uh socialize yourself with with other
people so so yeah so I mean I I I
completely I completely um I you know I
completely agree with with with that
yeah so it's like the you're saying kind
of an individual part which may overlaps
with self-empathy you have to be able to
be aware of who you are as a as a
individual that's right perhaps yeah
that's right well H how I'm just really
curious is like I mean I was in China
1990 uh just kind of did a little bit of
traveling through there it was just
before the real boom I think really
started taking off but uh you know that
the sense that we get I think here in
the United States is uh China is more of
an authoritarian you know um you know
patriarchal kind of a a society and
that's very much is follow the rules you
know certain people are in charge uh you
know it's
hierarchical which is very different
model from empathy empathy is about
feeling everyone for their humanity and
you know how do I interact with your
humanity and how do you see my Humanity
yes and um so it seems like it's h for
to do that kind of a cultural change in
uh China for people to really value
empathy that's uh um that's quite a
cultural shift yeah I mean like I I
think that you've you you know you
really hit the uh the nail on the head I
mean that's exactly the problem where
there is a hierarchy where um you know
power is distributed unevenly within
China and so um you know the pow that b
feel that you know it is their right to
sort of uh bully the powerless and and
and that's why we lack a culture of
empathy um um in China and um you know
that's not just the problem of empathy
that's a problem with um communication
and creativity as well where
communication you need and some you need
equality I mean you need to respect and
Trust the people you're communicating
with and if you don't then there's no
communication and you know China lacks
communication as well and creativity is
is a culture you know uni culture of
innovation where you're not afraid to
lose face yeah where you're not afraid
to make mist mes where you're not afraid
to you know offend your superiors and
you know these three things empathy
communication creative they're all
related and China is very much in need
of these three things if it is to to
progress as a society and as a
civilization and um you know you hit the
nail on the head which is fundamentally
it's a question of you know um power
distribution and um respect for for for
for everyone and and the poal system I
mean that's I mean fun L yeah I mean I
mean I mean if China is is is is to
progress as an economy as a society as a
people then it has to fundamentally look
at reexamine its political system and
question um the the sort of
effectiveness of it in a 21st century
global economy so it's really how do you
create that empathy then within society
and and how is that movement going in in
China in terms of I mean your school is
kind of progressive it sounds like it's
kind of on The Cutting Edge of this how
does it look at a larger societal level
are there um like here in the United
States there's businesses that are
trying to implement more empathy I mean
it's not like America is some kind of a
par you know Paragon of of of empathy so
it's really a worldwide you know shift
that needs to happen it seems to me but
I'm just wondering are there businesses
or you know kind of doing this or other
schools what's the the picture in China
for empathy the develop velopment of
empathy you know I believe this I I
believe very strongly that empathy is
about being an effective School an
effective business about being an
effective society which is the ability
to channel um the creativity and the
energy of everyone involved um to create
something great um you know you you look
at companies that treat their employeers
with respect um you know companies like
Google and apple and and Facebook and
which basically encourage them to be
creative individuals and they sort of
remove what's called Scientific
Management from from from the equation
where you know you know I mean people
aren't treated like animals anymore I
mean these are creative companies that
that have shown tremendous growth and I
think that any company that um employs a
culture of empathy effectively will show
um tremendous growth and that and that
and that's just because of of the way
that Americans have been educated if you
look at um you know the sort of
Education that that really smart
Americans um receive they go to the
workplace expecting to be treated as
equals expecting expected to be given
autonomy and freedom to pursue what they
love and I mean I mean if you look at
companies that do that they Thrive and
companies that sort of try to uh work
against that uh they suffer um so um
that's that's what what what's happening
in America where you know there's there
there are these showcases for empathy um
in China right now the issue is again uh
there is no word for empathy there's no
understanding of the word empathy in in
this culture what's the closest word in
China in Chinese the closest word is
sympathy which is T which is a same
feeling which is same feeling yeah yeah
it's not empathy yeah and compassion is
there a word for compassion that's
similar but not quite yeah there there's
word for for compassion but you know
empathy it's a very much a technical
term um with a lot of
thatted in in the language um so so you
know so I mean what needs right now is
to sort of first be introduced to the
concept empathy and that's what we're
trying to do here where we're trying to
show that if you we move uh pressure and
hierarchy and S testing from the chin
system you focus more on a cultur of
empathy students become happier they
become more motivated they become more
creative they become more driven to to
learn they become better at
collaborating together um and and you
know that's what's happening with our
students so we feel very strongly that
first we need a showcase for what is
possible within trans education reform
what empathy could lead to so kind of
like a model you want to model it within
your school so it's like something that
others can look at and see
exactly exactly I think that you know
right right now a lot of business are
willing to discuss empathy U because of
what Microsoft what Apple what Google
were able to accomplish if it weren't
for these companies then um then I mean
what then they would you not have you
would not have that many companies
talking about empathy right now yeah so
um so right now our school you know I
feel very strongly that that we're a lab
um and we're showcased for what is
possible um and you know empathy um even
though it's not articulated explicitly
it very much is in in in the blood the
culture of of of who we are and what we
do
well one thing uh even in the United
States sometimes uh empathy is I mean it
kind of infuses everything you know I
mean all human interaction even if
there's a higher you know a kind of an
authoritarian kind of a relationship
even here there's still empathy you know
you can't it's just kind of we're wired
into it but it's kind of like how do we
maximize it right how do we raise the
level of empathy but it does seem to be
important to have a vocabulary for it
you know what I mean to have an explicit
vocabulary about you can have a whole
series of of other words like
individualism or or collaboration but to
have a clear vocabulary same me to be
very
important you you you know you know it's
you know China is a very uh different
Society from America and I'll give I'll
give an example where you know when I
walk the street um you know I'm I'm sort
of beeped by a car and you know one time
I've been hit by a car you know and had
the right of way I I I was crossing the
street and I was hit by a car and you
know I've actually looked in the eyes of
drivers and you know when they drive
they don't seem to have awareness of
other drivers they don't seem to have
awareness of pedestrians they feel that
I have a car and and I I I can go and do
whatever I want right you know it you
know it's it's sort of the culture of
mutual respect is is not it doesn't
exist in China it's it's it's not a
culture of power and facei yeah um and
and shame it's it's not a culture of of
empathy and you're exactly right where
where you know I mean when people um
when when Americans are together you
know there is there is um a culture of
empathy um at at the you know at the
most fundamental level you know even
stranger can can can express empathy to
each other in China strangers cannot
express empathy to to each other
families can though you know families
are very much tight uh Network um you
you know very much well connected um so
you know that's a fundamental
misunderstanding of uh of the world
about China China you know as a nation
is actually very fragile and very weak
um and that's because there's no empathy
the social glue to to have everyone uh
together and think nationally um China
very much is a clan-based family based
society well you know I'm I'd be glad to
uh try to network together uh with
yourself and other schools maybe do some
panel discussions around empathy so that
uh you know that You' be connected to
others here talking about empathy abely
and if you saw like and maybe you get
support you could get support for lesson
plans and activities something that
makes it more explicit you know explicit
you know it's it's there's all these
processes like active listening
reflective
listening uh you know mirroring
exercises there's a lot of things that
can be done to kind of
explicitly uh you know give lessons into
the nature of of of empathy and yeah
that that's kind of like building here
now right I mean you know what we do is
very special in China uh what we do is
very distinctive and you know our
students in this program love what
what's happening you know they feel
better as um individuals and as students
and they feel they feel as though
they're respected they feel as though
they're empowered
in our
culture um but you know the parents
themselves are under tremendous pressure
because you know they obviously have
different Social Circles which tell
which tell them you know like what is
your kid doing your kid wants to go to
America why is he not sing for the sat
right now why he's not memorizing words
why is like why is he reading books and
you know going to Africa to do service
on him what's the point of that and so
what's really important for us as a
school is connect with other schools
that's your philosophy and you know we
want we really want to be part of Global
Network um because you know what we do
in China is so challenging so you know
it's good it's good for our students
because it sort of reinforces the values
of what we of what we try to teach here
but at the same time you know it also
brought BR the horizons which leads to
you know greater empathy yeah so I I
mean you know if you could if you can be
the facilitator for this you know help
us you know put us in touch with other
schools you know I hope very much that
in the future you know uh you could
arrange for our students to discuss with
um the students from from other schools
I mean I mean I talk I talk about the
theory a lot but I very much well would
you know think that you would benefit a
lot from talking to our students yeah
absolutely we can we can do a panel
discussions we can bring in some panel
discussions and they can be recorded as
well and put them online I like would
you like to meet one one of our students
right now sure so she can disc you sure
I'll be back okay let me turn on the
lights too it's getting darker here all
right I I'll back in minutes yes so um I
I've asked a student to uh to join the
conversation okay great but you know I I
feel very strongly that you know I mean
I'm Western educated um and um I think
that um your audience you yourself will
benefit a lot from talking to one of our
students who is not Western educated and
who's who went for the CH system and now
and now is is is in our our system uh
one thing I like to ask Al you know the
empathy is often seen as the metaphor is
is the the metaphor of standing in
someone else's shoes and looking through
someone else's eyes and what I always
like to do is ask people what is your
personal metaphor of empathy so for me
empathy is like a
cornucopia so do you have a if you just
from your own imagination What would
empathy be like to you if it's uh if
empathy was you know an animal or type
of BL or a machine or just anything like
that any kind of a
metaphor right well I mean like the
image that comes to mind is I mean um I
need time to think about this the first
thing that comes to mind is a dolphin
because you know dolphins are considered
you know um but um you know empathy
that's a very tough question um well
you're saying empathy is like a dolphin
right I mean um well I mean Dolphins
cons you know are considered to have um
empathy um I
mean you
know empathy
you know it's it's like water you know
it's it's like air it pervades
everything that is and it's fundamental
to life uh I I I don't see how societies
can function without um without ear or
water empathy I mean I mean um I
mean I I think if you ask me what it is
I I think I think I think have to say
water it nourishes us it's fundamental
to Who We Are it's fundamentally what we
are actually we're you know 80% water or
whatever but um um I mean it's a source
source of life I mean if water is to the
individual then empathy is to society I
don't see how societies can survive
about empathy and um you know and I
think that if um Society societies lack
empathy then they slowly slowly uh
degenerate so so yeah so they slowly
they slowly
dehydrate yeah yeah if you ask me for
the metaphor I would say MV is water
yeah I love it I think it's a great
metaphor so
yeah so yeah um you know I was asking I
I didn't I don't recall right off what
was your proposal for the Asoka uh
contest what was what what was it that
the actual proposal was I I mean like
like what we tryy to do here is we're
called empathy and practice so even
though we don't articulate it even
though we don't try to sort of
indoctrinate our students with it it is
fundamental to everything that we do you
know our Focus so we have we have
student focus in in in our program
that's fundamental to our identity as a
school the first is on Reading
literature um I want my students to
become lifelong readers um because you
know Reading literature it's
traditionally the best way to teach
empathy in schools I mean literature
fiction is fun fundamentally about
trying to understand the world through
the through the perspectives of
different characters and you know
writers themselves um are are
individuals with tremendous empathy for
for themselves and and and and for the
community so the So reading is so
fundamental to to what we do and I think
it's so unfortunate that reading has
become um increasingly uh Irrelevant in
schools not just in China but also in
America so so oh excuse me your um your
proposal then to aoko was kind of your
school itself was what you were kind of
showcasing and all the things that
you're you're you're saying you're
saying uh this is our our uh proposal
that we're putting and it's our school
which is really trying to incorporate uh
empathy within uh China yeah you know
empathy cannot be done half-heartedly
you know you can't have that you can
have a class on empathy it it has to be
it's like water it has to be it has to
prevent everything for it for it to to
work so you know like like the first
component is our reading program our
emphasize on reading and teaching
students the love of reading second is
on on on the idea of group dynamic where
we where group dynamic pervades every
class and we try to get our students uh
to learn to work together now to work
together is not that easy I mean like
you just you don't put like four people
together and says okay go do this I mean
there has to be um certain things that
are emphasized in good for example self-
understanding the understanding of your
own limitations um also the appreciation
of other people's strengths and
weaknesses um what appreciating that
different people bring different things
to the table and and appreciating that
third is to emphasiz evidence and logic
as a way to debate um and also to offer
specific feedback when when when you're
discussing I mean in kids I mean it's
very easy for them even adults it's very
easy for group discussion to generate
into um sort of um you know I mean like
insults um and sort ability to like hold
yourself back and to offer specific
feedback um to um ideas that that
requires empathy um and um and and so
what's really important also is that to
offer students feedback for what they do
so I mean the obvious feedback for
reading is that you know you're reading
more um the diff the level of difficult
the level of difficulty of what you're
reading is increasing so they feel a
sense of accomplishment but also group
work is very important because at the
end of the day there's something
concrete at the end of it so we try to
move away from test and more towards
papers presentations experiments um you
know we we we we read a lot of books um
of on Neuroscience the brain that
changes itself The Accidental The
Accidental mind F our brain we read a
lot of books that discuss uh the
importance of of empathy um so so I mean
like that's so you know empathy is very
fundamental to our culture and and to
our practices how are you GNA overcome
that vocabulary problem of not having
the word is it like you know the uh word
uh empathy was actually a German word
and that got kind of incorporated into
the English they just you know what I
mean so it's all but that's quite a long
process I don't know how you would oh
you got your student there here okay
great can you just hold on sure
Che so so I've asked one one of our
students to uh to join us oh great um
this is Ed and we're having a step
conversation edn um this is Rebecca
she's she's one of our grade 11 students
oh great
hi hi so I'm coming closer okay so so um
uh Rebecca has been in our program um
since since the first day and what we're
talking about right now um what we're
talking about right now is is the word
empathy and how you know first of all we
can't translate the word in into Chinese
we we've been trying for like um you
know many many months to translate the
word into Chinese why can't we translate
the word into Chinese what's the
problem um I think there isn't a word in
Chinese that's as broad as that it has
there's small words that sort of means
um thinking um for the other people
or like that but they're not as broad as
this word is and somehow they just don't
really fit together well how how about
we coin a word we create a word right
now um so the the original word for
empathy was German and it meant feeling
into someone else
into it's it's Ein feling which is
feeling into so as I sit here and look
at you I feel into your EXP experience
so it would be feeling and into so what
would that be in Chinese like we' need
feel and then the and into is there
a couple of Chinese words that uh like
what's
feeling
G
G is feeling
right yeah I mean like like I mean the
problem word empathy is you know I mean
it's it's been I mean it's been such a
phenomenal part of western civilization
that the word itself brings up a lot of
connotations oh just a second I'm sorry
your image just froze if you could
sometimes if that happens if you hit the
you know oh there it goes okay sorry
okay sorry go ahead right I mean the
problem with the word empathy it's why
it's so hard to translate as Rebecca
just mentioned is that you know the co
the word has been so intrinsic in Wern
civilization for so long that it
automatically brings up connotations and
ideas and images that right now don't
exist in in China so even were to create
a word um that were that were to
basically capture the essence of it it
still wouldn't have the meaning and the
impact that that the word has in um is
in the English language uh can we do it
as a fun
exercise all
right by I come up a word in Chinese
that means empathy or captures the
essence of empathy and and it starts
with feeling and you just said want what
was it again feeling
g g g g
Ganer yeah okay and into what is
into singu singu ganja
Inu yeah it doesn't work huh it doesn't
well we tried we
tried right but I mean I mean you know
Rebecca's one one our students and um I
asked to join us because I was hoping
that maybe that from the perspective of
her student she can share of us you know
the importance of empathy our in our
school and how we sort of try to educate
students um and sort of try to like
teach them empathy here so what have you
learned about empathy uh in this
school
uh so I was I was thinking about the
batswana trip that we took uh a month
ago and our winter vacation we went to
batswana it was the first time for
almost all of us um in
Africa and um I think we went in with a
lot of stereotyp stereotypes
and but it turned out to be really
different than what we expected um the
people there were very nice and we kept
talking on about this point um they
greeted each other on the streets they
were very nice to us um
so I think and we also did Service
Learning there
um and well I think just all these added
up
and
oh but is really good what specifically
service learning that that sort of um
that sort of um focus on
empathy um we are all us I think most of
us are this single child at our homes um
like I'm not accustomed to constantly
thinking about someone else like a
brother or a sister um feeling okay she
can I was at a Homestay family um and
she like the girl I was staying with she
had a she had a brother and a sister a
little brother and a little sister and
when we while we were eating she was
constantly saying don't get too close to
the television or you can't eat with
your hands like that and have you washed
your hands and she was constantly
thinking about them and it just I felt
like so I never had that experience
where I was just worrying about someone
else along the time and during the
servus learning process we worked with
children that had um down syndromes and
that and some had difficulties
expressing themselves so I was sitting
with that one girl who couldn't speak
and um and we were supposed to draw
something but she had problems wrapping
the the pen so she so we just sat there
for half an hour
and so during that half an hour it was a
really long time for me just thinking
about what she want what she was
thinking about and I think that's
probably the longest time I spend just
just getting into someone others head
and just trying to feel what they're
feeling right now like she she kept
looking at um the people having lunch
over there and I think she was thirsty
and then I think like and I asked um a
uh a teacher there and like they sort of
communicated in a way and I got her some
water so it was it was a really
different experience for me yeah so you
you've grown up in a in a in a family
where you're the only child and so you
could just think about yourself all the
time and here you were seeing how other
children and large families had to kind
of think about each other all the time
yeah so I never really had that
experience um and I just just honestly
speaking I never felt that I lacked that
much on that um on that I had classmates
I felt well I I made friends and all
that because I never really felt that um
that that difference so that was the
time where I really thought I'm I'm
lacking a lot of things here actually oh
see if feel like you're lacking that
family that larger family or you're just
lacking
something I just I think it's lacking
um
just
the I think it's lacking the thing that
um just when some when you constantly
think about someone else just constantly
being aware that there are other people
around you and when I'm at home then
there's just me and this very easily
just to think about yourself and just
forget the rest of the world or
something yeah right but but you know I
mean like like I I'll make a larger
point which is you know in my experience
um you know chines students have very
limited experiences you know they go to
school they go home that's about it they
don't date they don't uh work they don't
um have real interest outside school and
so because their experience is limited
their emotional range is also limited
and that hinders development of of
empathy well uh for me one part of
empathy is kind of feeling into someone
else's experience and it sounded like
you were uh feeling into the experience
of the people that were there kind of
feeling what it's like to be thinking
about your brothers and sisters and uh
I'm just curious who did you feel the
most closest
to when you were
there um excuse me can you repeat that
question who did you feel the closest
did you have did you feel having the
closest feeling to kind of the closest
emotional feeling
um I think it was the girl I stayed with
in the Homestay family yeah we I stayed
there for one night and
uh it was is we got a lot of time just
to talk talk to each other um we talk
very late into the night um so we got
got a lot of time to get to know each
other and I get I got to know her family
she heard about mine oh great well we're
looking at how we were just talking
about how we can perhaps network with
others you know other schools maybe here
in the United States to actually kind of
talk about empathy and looking at
different ways to uh deepen uh empathy
and to uh build what I call a culture of
empathy so how do we create an
environment that's kind of supportive of
people connecting and uh seeing each you
know seeing the world through each
other's eyes so I'm really looking
forward to
that yeah I mean you know I mean please
please make the the introduction um you
know if if if possible you know you know
we have video facilities um you know
Skype but also video conferencing so um
and you know I mean like if if they were
want to visit China then uh we would we
would love to host them we have um some
students coming in from Thailand on on
Sunday to spend a week W with us and you
know it's it's opportunity for us to
expose our students to you know um
different perspectives and um did um and
so you know and and so I mean we are
very well much equipped to host schools
and you know our schools would love to
to visit other countries as well so
you're really open for connecting with
other uh right with other schools so
I'll I'll do what I can then to uh uh
kind of see if I can facilitate that and
I think our our next step will be maybe
a panel discussion we can have uh some
teachers and and are you a teacher or
administrator there or I'm not sure what
what your role
is um I I run the national division okay
so I'm administrator but also teach as
as I mean as well so here you know we
don't really um clarify roles and
responsibilities like we're like we see
ourselves as a community so everyone has
responsibility to help contribute um and
that also Fosters a culture of empathies
so you know Rebecca um is my teaching
assistant in an English class um so and
she's she she also works you know in a
student council so you know she also has
different roles responsibilities so you
know we we we we we try to sort of you
know flatten the hierarchy we we we we
try to like um we we try to basically
get rid of boundaries and and and try
and try to create a community of we call
Learners I have had a little bit of
bronchitis last couple months so I'm
sorry about coughing a little bit here
um so yeah okay so I think we we'll kind
of bring it to a close we've been at it
for about an hour but we'll we'll keep
that in mind as the next thing is I'll
try to get some other uh people who are
uh in the schools and we'll see about
doing a panel discussion around this and
and yeah that's then just keep kind of
building on I'm really excited uh
because this is kind of the first
connection I've had to China you know
around this project and so this is
really great for me I'm just really
enjoying it is I mean empathy is
completely new in in in in China we're
we're doing our best to sort of promote
it um but I mean you know it is an
uphill battle so whatever allies we we
can find in the process you know we're
very
grateful okay well then um we'll end it
there and uh we'll kind of communicate
via email about the next steps then and
I and I really appreciate you taking the
time to you know talk about your
project you you you organiz things and
you know helping us um link link with
with other people okay my pleasure okay
goodbye what was your oh what was your
name
again Rebecca Rebecca so Rebecca and
you'll have to pronounce yours again
sorry j Jung
j j
j
sorry doing my best okay goodbye then
till the next
time bye bye see the world through other
people's eyes now empathy is a quality
of character that can change the world